How should you behave on Facebook and how should you behave on Twitter?
I think Twitter drives me a little bit crazy,
you know,
um,
I'm on it a fair bit.
I'm not sure it's a good thing.
And I tend to distribute things that are alarming,
let's say in some sense maybe they are alarming ideological,
ideologically,
they're disturbing.
And I was thinking about that today in preparation for this talk.
And I wasn't really sure that was necessarily a good idea because there are a
lot of alarming things happening all the time,
everywhere obviously.
Um,
and now we can share all of them always all the time.
And so that means that instead of hearing about one alarming thing a day,
you're hearing about like 500 alarming things a day.
And so then,
you know,
what are you supposed to do about that?
Is that,
does that indicate the state that there's a state of emergency?
Well,
you don't know cause you don't know how to calibrate the information.
So I was thinking,
well maybe the right way to behave on Twitter is only two forward good things
that are happening.
You know,
cause there's lots of good things that are happening.
But I actually don't know the answer to that.
I,
I have no idea.
And I don't think anybody else does either.
I do know that there are studies with regards to Facebook that showed that the
more time that you spend on Facebook,
the more depressed you are and that it looks like it's a causal relationship
rather than just a correlational relationship.
And it seems to have something to do with the fact that Facebook is one of those
platforms where everybody puts up an advertisement for their life.
Right?
It's like,
here I am with my new girlfriend in The Bahamas being happy and here I am in a
mountain being happy.
And it's like,
it's not you like miserable with the cover over your head,
unable to get out of bed.
You don't,
you don't,
you don't broadcast that.
You can think,
well,
it means you're presenting people with a falsely positive view of your life and
then they compare their lives to it and they come up short and you think,
well that's a kind of deception.
But by the same token,
you don't stop random strangers on the street and tell them how miserable your
life is.
Right?
They don't want to hear about that.
They,
they want to see a facade of normality in,
in,
you know,
just casual day to day interactions.
And so part of pro social behavior is only to put what's at least,
you know,
normative and good forward.
So it doesn't matter.
I mean,
so I don't think that's necessarily deception,
but the mass consequences of that is something that we don't understand at all.
And so,
well,
so with that sort of introduction,
I'm going to kind of walk you through my experience with social media and let's
say the old media,
for lack of a better word,
and I'll try to give you a balanced account and to tell you,
well,
it's to see if I can draw some conclusions about what's happening.